well back with my pack uh now following
our earlier debate about Ukraine it's a
very sad breaking news it's just been
confirmed that two British men who were
volunteering in Ukraine Chris parry and
Andrew Bagshaw had been killed they're
reporting missing in January Mr parry's
family confirmed tonight they were both
killed while assisting a humanitarian
evacuation and if that doesn't toughen
our resolve in this country to do
whatever we can to help Ukraine win that
War I don't know what would
well coming next I'm joined now by the
Titans Royal correspondent and author of
Portia is the hidden power behind the
crown Valentine low plus our pack is
still here and what the temperature
Tyson Porter owned Adrian so Valentine
you're over in America at the moment
um with uh promoting your book
fascinating piece in the New York Times
has just come out headlines has Prince
Harry's confessional tour run its course
even in the United States the New York
Times says which has a high tolerance
for Redemptive stories about overcoming
trauma and family dysfunction the tide
seems to be turning it's one thing to be
criticized it's another to be openly
ridiculed that's pretty heavy coming
from the New York Times
it is because they would be very much on
the Harry and Megan's side but one does
sense that well there's still you know
quite a strong Bedrock have been in
favor of them that they are less popular
uh than they were over here and you know
there is so much moaning that you can
put up with isn't right I I completely
agree I mean how do you keep doing it
where is it where can they go they've
trashed all their family repeatedly
there's no one left to trash
um what about prince Andrew what impact
is all his scandal having does it really
resonate in America in the same way even
though it arguably is a lot more serious
uh I don't think it does quite in the
same way because it's it's sort of not
really an ongoing soap opera is it the
good thing about Harry and Megan is
there's there's such a strong narrative
tribe there isn't it to keep everyone
interested whereas Andrew he's he's just
a mess who messed up uh and sort of
covered himself and the family in shame
but it it doesn't really go anywhere do
you think either Robin Valentine will be
at the coronation either prince Andrew
or Harry Megan
I I suspect prince Andrew will be I
think uh the king will invite him and
and he if invited he'll definitely be
there I think in terms of Harry and
Megan I think they'll certainly be
invited uh because uh for for King
Charles not to invite his son would
really be seen as sort of petty and and
vindictive uh and not in the spirit of I
wouldn't invite one of my sons if they'd
done that to the family I can tell you
they'd be absolutely NFI
um well you're not King that's why
you're not King yes well at the moment
at the moment Valentine at the moment
stranger things have happened
um Richard the Royals the coronation it
remains it is a soap opera but they're
real people uh we're we're hurtling
towards the coronation in a few weeks
time in early May what's he going to do
Charles about his brother now in the
headlines again because of the Gilley
Maxwell uh interview with Harry and
Megan his son in a trashing it's very
easy he has to retain the moral High
Ground of course he has to invite all
his family whether or not they attend I
suspect uh the Valentine's right I don't
think Harry and Megan will attend I
think backdoor channels will say please
stay in and invite them I mean because
because you've you've got to you've got
to retain the moral Eiger and you're
King you're bringing people together
you're leading from the front a whole
nation and just don't stir the pot
um whereas I suspect prince Andrew I
suspect he will attend and be sort of
stuck on the back row Paula the resident
defender of all things Megan and Harry I
mean why if they hate the royal family
and the monarchy so much and trash the
institutions
whatever you want to call stop saying
the word hate no one has suggested that
hate is relevant in this issue given
they've caused so much damage to the
institutional reputation of the monarchy
why would they want to be a coronation
of a new monarch given the fact that
they have raised difficulties that they
have had well they said the rules and
races then said we didn't mean to
consolidation that's what we're talking
about the problems that they have raised
let's be clear about all the life and
the problems I have raised are really
serious mental health issues issues
around abuse issues around why do you
believe that and Prejudice why do you
believe that but it's not about whether
I believe them why it's not allowed
without any proof what it's about is
that they think it's true and what you
need to understand is
nothing to do with whether they think
it's true that's either true or it's not
thank you
or not if that was the case then I
wouldn't be in a job what fact is your
truth may not be my truth
and it will be very different to all of
us that doesn't mean Hello I know and
I'm choosing to ignore my show that's my
show and I'll cut off your mic in a
minute uh here's the bottom line there
is no my truth your truth
and you know what really got my goat
about those two was the two most
damaging things they said in that first
Oprah winathon where the the Royals have
been racist to them about the skin color
of their of their son and secondly uh
Meghan Markle had gone to a senior
Palace person who had banned her from
getting help for her Suicidal Thoughts
neither of those things appear in his
book
he's already reigned back now on the
racism charge so that's not what he
meant when we all knows exactly what
they meant they said it we watched them
say it and secondly Richard on the
mental health thing again a very big
weapon to hurl at the palace that they
were callous about a Suicidal Thoughts
not a word has been mentioned since
nothing in the Netflix documentary
nothing in the book I don't think it
happened Harry and I had to leave my
last job but not believing it how can
Harry have therapy exactly but she not
have therapy she had a therapist or
speed dial unless he didn't he did
unless he didn't think that she deserved
it I mean the whole thing's a complete
nonsense you can't the queen we just
couldn't trust anything up though didn't
she when she said
um at that memories
and so no and so what happens is when
you have a situation where somebody is
in pain where you say something that you
do not consider to be insulting where
you do not consider to be hurtful or in
any way intentional even but that
doesn't mean that the other person
doesn't take it that way that doesn't
mean that the other person doesn't want
to leave that discussion
about what's happening we're talking
about going on Oprah Winfrey and calling
the royal family racists and then two
years later after all the damage of that
race charge against the royal family and
they never named the racist Harry now
says we didn't say anyone was racist the
evil British press who are responsible
for everything you know Harry's World
he's technically right they didn't say
that
he's a decision
that's a different topic that's the same
topic was there a Nuance there that
people were led to believe that have you
always defended the offensive or was it
a new trait of yours
yes what do we do about the Royals well
first of all I do not think that Harry
and Megan should be at the corner no for
one very simple reasons
if they're there they then become the
story and they'll be taping everybody
and heaven knows you know private
conversations the rules will be very
uneasy so I do not think they should
come to the coronation I don't think it
matters whether Andrew's there or not
because I'd rather think that he also
you know he will just be in the
background and there'll be a comment I
agree he won't try and take the
attention he's not going to take all the
cameras I wouldn't trust if I were the
royal family I wouldn't trust the
sussexes as far as I could for what
appears to be reconciliation it takes
you don't get reconciliation releasing a
410 page book trash in your family he's
not the first one to release an
autobiography let me run out of time the
first but you know what we can continue
this you can come back again because I I
like the new Paula irritating but I
quite like it